If there's one thing kids love, it's TV shows
aimed directly at their age group. Whether
it's tales of transforming robots straight
from Japan, or mystical creatures living in
their own back yards, the show's we watch
as kids tend to be remembered as some of the
best we ever witnessed. But maybe they actually
were. So for studios looking to turn nostalgia
into box office dollars, they should at least
be turning to the right ones. Here are Screen
Rant's 10 Amazing Kids TV Shows That Would
Make Awesome Movies.
M.A.S.K.
In a world where former toy lines like Transformers
and G.I. Joe can become large-scale movies,
why wouldn't a movie mixing the best of both
worlds work even more? Especially with some
Mission: Impossible thrown in just to be safe.
The operatives of M.A.S.K. - the Mobile Armored
Strike Kommand - rely on superpowered masks,
transforming cars, and space age technology
to keep the evil forces of VENOM at bay. Since
there isn't much beyond those plot points
that would need to be adapted, there's no
reason why the right writers couldn't make
a M.A.S.K. story worth telling.
Gargoyles
When an ancient team of Gargoyles - noble
warriors who turn to stone during the day
- are lifted from a Scottish castle all the
way to New York City, it's the ultimate fish
out of water story... except the fish are
ancient winged creatures eager to explore
the modern world. It didn't take long for
the cartoon to become a massive hit, and its
themes and stories are already dark enough
to appeal to an older audience. There's no
doubt about it: a big screen take on Goliath
and his Gargoyles couldn't just work - it's
a hit in the making.
Voltron
This one's an easy sell: a team of five people
all pilot massive robot lions that, when combined
together, form a towering robotic wwarrior
known as Voltron: Defender of the Universe.
You shouldn't really need any more reasons
why this would work, since kids didn't when
the cartoon first made it to American homes.
Despite being written and acted in Japanese,
and deciphered without a translator, the lions
were cool enough to make Voltron the most
successful syndicated kids' show of its time.
So if the time right for a Power Rangers reboot,
Voltron can't be too far behind.
Thundercats
What could be better to a kid than hearing
they might one day wake up in a full-grown,
heroic body, ready to do battle like a cartoon
hero? That's the main plot of ThunderCats,
when Lion-O and his group of friends travel
from their doomed planet to Third Earth, arriving
and waking from stasis to find that they're
now full-grown. The villain, enemies, and
larger mythology of the Eye of Thundera all
make it an even better story, but considering
the show's place in pop culture, nobody needs
any convincing.
Power Rangers
It's one thing to be chosen to become a martial
artist superhero, but given a robotic animal
to pilot on top of it? The Power Rangers are
the kings of kids cartoon heroes, recruited
to battle the galaxy's worst villains just
for being "teenagers with attitude." It's
hard to know what the real hook of the show
actually is: the teens transformed into neon-colored
ninja warriors, or when they're forced to
combine their individual vehicles into the
epic Megazord to take on an oversized enemy.
It's easy to see why a Power Rangers movie
is actually in production, but the filmmakers
still need to capture the spirit, while keeping
it cool for more than just diehard fans - easier
said than done.
Samurai Jack
It's honestly surprising that this series
hasn't already been adapted to live-action,
since its unique story and inspired premise
basically demand it. When the title Samurai
has completed the training needed to defeat
the evil Demon Aku, his enemy pulls a fast
one, sending the samurai far into the future,
buying himself enough time to prepare for
his attack. Dropped into a technologically
advanced, but fascist and dystopic society,
Samurai Jack must find the way home to keep
this world ruled by Aku from ever existing,
as Aku sends wave after wave of killers and
light-hearted hitmen to take him out. Time
travel, samurai, demons - what more could
you want?
Biker Mice From Mars
It may be the most far-fetched premise on
our entire list, but trust us: the story of
three mice-men from Mars who protect Earth
from the evil that destroyed their home planet
- from the backs of customized motorcycles
- is one worth seeing adapted. The fact that
they're actually mice men could be hard to
swallow, but the story of three grease monkey
aliens could give fans of the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles another franchise to root for
- and give the Biker Mice a modern reboot
to learn from.
SilverHawks
We've got shows in space, and shows following
cops - but what about a cartoon series following
futuristic cops with metallic wings? That's
right, the SilverHawks may not be the most
original idea for a kids' show, but it's hard
to argue with just how cool they are. The
show was a spiritual successor to ThunderCats
in several ways, so assuming that the same
connection could be translated to the big
screen (with a big enough budget to do their
winged crimefighting justice), especially
in the rage of the "shared universe" at all
cost...
C.O.P.S.
To be clear, we men's the cartoon series Cops,
not the prime time cop series. No, we're referring
to the Central Organization of Police Specialist.
In other words, a team of the very best law
men and women from across America, all recruited
to stop Big Boss from taking over Empire City.
Did we mention their leader was almost killed
by Big Boss, and had his Torso replaced with
cybernetic parts? If the idea of a Robocop
team-up aimed at kids doesn't get your hopes
for a great action comedy soaring, ghats your
own fault.
Dungeons & Dragons
Ask any fan of role playing games, or D&D
in particular, and they'll tell you that as
cool as it is to step into the shoes of a
monster or witch hunter, justplayingas
one doesn't even come close. Thanks to this
animated series, kids could dream that they,
too would plunge into the distant world of
Never Land, only to wake up having been shrunk
down into a forest-sized game of chess, and
having the mysterious Dungeon Master assign
them their skills. In other words, in a world
where lines between video games and all other
entertainment are starting to blur, seeing
a group of kids have to deal with
that revelation.